[clears throat]
>> This weekend we have reached a turning
point in the war. It's possible that in
a few hours
or by tomorrow we will have reached the
point of no return.
Donald Trump has threatened the Iranians
saying that on Tuesday if the Iranians
still refuse to open the Strait of
Hormuz
then the Americans will destroy
the Iranian power plants
and bridges and universities.
Basically the Americans will start
attacking critical civilian
infrastructure which will force Iranians
to strike hard against the GCC
the oil fields, the desalination plants,
the universities as well. And this would
mean that the world would lose
20% of its energy supply.
And that would be catastrophe for the
global economy.
It would uh de-industrialize the world
and would create global famine among
other problems. Okay, so next few hours,
next day um we could reach the point of
no return in this war. Hopefully Trump
is bluffing because he has known to
bluff before.
In fact, he's issued many ultimatums to
Iran before and then he sort of tackle,
right? Trump always chickens out and he
said, "You know what? I said a day, but
I'll give you a week instead."
But this time I want to show you that
it's different.
I want to show you that this weekend the
Americans went all in, they launched a
ground invasion, it failed, and instead
of saying, "You know what?
We probably can't beat Iran. Let's
negotiate a peace deal." What the
Americans will do is they will go all in
now and launch a full-scale run
invasion, call a national draft, and the
world will never be the same again.
Okay? So, this is the tweet that Donald
Trump
sent to the Iranians.
And he calls them
crazy bastards.
And he [laughter] says, "Praise be to
Allah." So, a lot of people think he is
now deranged. Clearly, he's angry at the
Iranians.
All right.
All right. So, um
the Americans and the Israelis have
constantly escalated attacks against
civilian targets in Iraq. So, Trump
ordered the destruction of Iran's
largest bridge. Okay?
All right.
Right here, right? Guys, you guys see
that?
Okay? And this is considered a war crime
because you're not supposed to target
target civilian infrastructure.
Now, you can make the argument that this
is dual use, meaning that the military
uses it as well, but everything is dual
use, right? Because the the military
also uses water. They also use
electricity. Their kids also go to
university. So,
um
there's a great fear now that we're
already at the point of no return. And
the Iranians themselves have promised to
start to attack universities in the GCC
as well, okay, in retaliation.
Um so, if Trump were to destroy the
Iranian power plants,
uh this would be devastating for the
Iranian economy. And there's news now
that Iran is organizing
a
uh
protest where young people are asked to
go to power plants and form a human
chain so that if the jets come destroy
the power plants, they will be destroyed
as well.
Um so some people think that okay, this
is the Iranians calling the bluff of
Trump. That's not a good idea because
the first day of the war, the Americans
killed uh 168 schoolgirls in southern
Iran. So this shows that the Iranian
it's the Americans and the Israelis
don't really care about human life.
Um but by doing this
if the Americans actually do destroy uh
power plants and they do kill a lot a
lot of young people in the process, what
this would do is galvanize the nation
into total war, okay? So
what's important to understand is that
um throughout this war
there have been
different voices in Iran, okay? Some
like the
the Islamic Revolutionary Guard want
total war, but there are also some who
are worried about the economic damage
because of this war. They're also
worried about giving power to too much
giving too much power to the military,
okay? But if Donald Trump goes and
attacks these power plants, then the
Iranians will be going to total war.
They will be totally committed to
destroying the American military
presence in the Middle East as well as
the global economy, okay?
And unfortunately the Americans and the
Israelis don't really care because
they're committed to destroying
um Iran as a viable nation-state.
Already we are seeing increases in fuel
prices, okay? So if you are in the
um
red, it means that you've seen prices go
up a lot.
Okay? If you're on the red. So America,
Australia, um they've seen prices
skyrocket.
China has also seen prices skyrocket as
well as well as Europe.
This is only just the beginning.
We can we can expect gas prices to
skyrocket
so much that it essentially collapses
the civilian aviation industry. Meaning
meaning that in the future you want to
fly, it might cost you 10 times as much
as it does now, okay? And this will
happen very very quickly. But again, the
main issue
and I need to emphasize this, the main
issue is not the fuel. The main issue is
the fertilizer.
And the fertilizer is important because
you need fertilizer to grow food and we
are in the planting season. You guys
don't know this, but it is because of
fertilizer that we are that we are
allowed to support 8 billion people.
If we didn't have access to fertilizer,
we could only grow enough food to
support 1 to 2 billion people.
And unfortunately, this means that
Africa
and parts of South South Asia, a lot of
people there will starve to death. So
the main concern is famine, okay? Not
airline tickets.
All right, let's continue.
All right.
So as this war is progressing, we need
to step back and recognize that this is
a global war. So
um
the the Ukrainians used drones to attack
and destroy an oil depot, an oil
terminal in
Russia. And this means now that 40%
40% guys
of Russia's oil exports have gone
offline.
Right?
So what's
is that not only
is the Strait of Hormuz closed, but the
Americans are also attacking uh Russia's
oil, okay? So, you have drone strikes in
terminals, but also you don't
you don't see this in the news, but also
there's um
a basically naval blockade. So, if you
are a Russian
uh oil tanker, if the American the
Americans come and catch you, they'll
take your oil, okay? So, this is
basically piracy.
>> [snorts]
>> So, in other words, the American
strategy before was, okay, before we
were the world's
uh global reserve currency.
And as a result,
we uh encouraged global trade. But now
that we are not But now that our economy
is suffering, well, let's just control
the sea lanes, okay? So, that's the
American strategy moving forward. All
right. Um so, new news from Germany is
that if you are a German male under 45,
okay? Basically from 17 to 45, this age
group this age group, you are not
allowed to leave the country for more
than 3 months without
army permission.
This is a prelude to a national draft.
Okay? And why is Germany doing this?
Because Germany is an industrial nation.
And if Russian energy supply goes
offline, if energy from the GCC goes
offline, Germany has no choice but to
remilitarize and create its own energy
supplies.
Okay? So, Germany must go to war. It has
absolutely no choice in the matter.
All right.
So, let's talk briefly about what's
going to happen over the next year. So,
as I said, before the United States was
the global reserve currency.
And that mean meant basically that for
every transaction that you made with US
dollars, they could tax you, okay?
Because they could they could inflate
the price of the US dollar. But now that
people are choosing to opt out of the US
dollar, for example, in China people are
buying more gold, right?
And people are using other currencies.
America, in order to maintain its
empire, has to change its strategy.
Now, the main source of American power
is its ability to control sea lanes,
okay? Because it it has military bases
all around the world, okay? So, in the
red, these are all areas with US bases.
And before it used these US bases in
order to maintain global trade.
But with nations choosing
to opt out of your system,
now your option now your strategy is to
blockade them, right? Create a naval
blockade, starve them of resources,
which forces them to come back to you
for trade access, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> So, we've got a new strategy where
America guaranteed global trade to
America basically being a mafia state,
being pirates, not allowing you to use
um sea lanes and giving you trade
access, okay? Does that make sense?
And believe it or not,
but America does not actually need to do
that much work in order to control trade
around the world. It just It just needs
to control certain trade or um certain
choke points, okay? So, the Panama Canal
is one choke point, and that's why about
a third of
um America's navy is deployed to the
Caribbean right now.
All right? And its main purpose is to
block off trade
um in the Western Hemisphere. So, if you
are China, if you are Japan, and you are
South Korea, if you want to access
Western resources, Western Hemisphere
resources, you need the permission from
the US government. And the um example,
of course, is Venezuela, where they
removed the president, and now they
basically have a a blockade over
Venezuela, and so the Venezuela
government is very cooperative, okay?
They're basically very obedient. There's
um and so what we can expect next is for
Trump to exert authority over Greenland.
Why? Because this is the Arctic choke
point, okay?
Which gives you access to Canada uh and
to Europe as well. We can also expect um
America to basically create a choke
point
over the Strait of Hormuz, right? So,
right now, the issue is that
the Iranians control the Strait of
Hormuz. But the Americans can also
choose to blockade the Strait of Hormuz.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right. The major choke point in the
world, of course, is something called
the Strait of Malacca.
Why? Because that This is where China
gets most of its resources from Africa,
from the Middle East, okay? Through this
very small choke point. And again,
unfortunately, there are lots of US
military bases in this area. So, as long
as America is able to maintain these
three major choke points, the Panama
Canal, um the Middle East, and the
Strait of Malacca, oh, and also, sorry,
Greenland as well, then America can
control naval access, okay? Trade
access, maritime navigation. It can
control all these things.
And so, what's going to happen is this.
The big event this year, moving forward,
is that Russia will militarize
its shadow fleet.
Okay? Basically, Russia has a shadow
fleet of about 1,000 uh ships. It will
provide mercenaries to these
and then it will start to uh engage
America in the oceans. The point is not
to defeat the American Navy. You can't
do that, okay? The point is to create a
war of attrition, where you know that
the Americans will have problems
rebuilding these ships. And these ships
are pretty old as well. And the sailors
are on them are pretty tired. So, you
just force them into conflict, and then
this naval capacity of the United States
will degrade over time, okay? This is
something to look out for over the next
year or 2 years. This conflict in the
seas that will arise between Russia and
the United States. Okay?
And then you ask yourself, okay, well,
what about China?
Because China is actually the main
beneficiary of um oceanic trade. And
China is going to do China, which is to
say that China is going to try to
negotiate between Russia and America,
and try to triangulate the two, and try
to come to peace with all two, okay? And
that often means paying both off, paying
both the Russians and paying the the
Americans off. And And that's what uh
that's what happened in May when Trump
visits China. Right?
Okay, we'll talk talk more about that
later on.
Okay.
So, the big news this weekend, and it's
something I want to focus on for the
rest of the lecture, is
the Americans said said that one of
their one of their jets, called an F-15,
this is about a $90 million
plane, okay?
It was shot down
over
uh Iran, okay?
Um basically in uh this area right here.
And you ask yourself, okay, the
Americans have air supremacy over Iran.
So, how is it possible for the Iranians
to shoot shoot down
um um plane? And the answer is this, the
US Air Force is not designed designed to
fight a long war. It's designed to fight
at most a two-week war.
If you fight for too long, you have
certain issues. One issue is
maintenance.
Okay?
Which is these are very expensive
planes. They require a lot of
maintenance. But if they're flying too
much, if they're
if they have too much work, they suffer
from wear and tear, okay? Another issue
is just fatigue, where these pilots are
being asked to work too hard, they get
tired, they get lazy. And the last thing
is this,
Iranian
um resilience.
Okay? And all this means is that
as you're bombing Iranians, the Iranians
have to figure out how to strike back at
you. Their radar system don't really
work, so what they use is use
heat-seeking missiles, okay? So rather
rather than try to figure out where you
are, they just fire missiles up in the
air and hope and hope to lock onto your
heat signature and knock you down, okay?
All right. So over time,
all this means is that as this war
progresses, if you insist on fighting a
air war, you're going to lose more and
more planes as your pilots get tired, as
maintenance issues arise, as Iranians
become much more creative in their
response.
Okay? So a pilot was shot down
and two pilots were able to eject safely
out of their plane.
Now, it is the policy of the American
military
to leave no man behind.
And this is the and Americans are one
one of the few
uh militaries that actually do this,
where if you're behind enemy lines, they
will try to rescue you. And they spend
years training you on how to evade uh
any captors. They'll spend a lot of
resources trying to save you.
And the propaganda is that this is to
show you how Americans really value
uh human life. And it's something
Americans are very proud of.
But another reason why Americans do this
is this optics.
>> [snorts]
>> Which is that the that the Americans
believe that the military is invincible.
And they spend a lot of money and
resources
in order to create this image, this aura
of invincibility and invulnerability.
So, if the Iranians are able to capture
a pilot and have him appear on Iranian
TV, this is a huge propaganda win for
the Iranians. Meaning this meaning that
if the Americans
the Americans will try your best the
Americans will try their best to save
you, but they can't save you and there's
a risk that they end up capturing you,
they'd rather have you killed. Okay?
Because they can't afford to lose this
propaganda war. For Americans everything
is optics. As I I'll show you later on,
this is going to be a huge issue in this
war, okay? As this war progresses.
Now,
there are a lot of issues
with um the story that's being told to
to us, okay? The Americans said that
they have successfully evacuated both
pilots. They said they saved both
pilots. But the issue is this. The issue
is that we know that
um the Americans created a makeshift
landing strip, basically an airport, a
small airport, 200 km
from
um where the airman actually
was knocked down. So, he had he had to
hike a long way in order to get to the
landing strip.
Also, he was injured. I mean, he he
broke his ankle or something, okay?
So, that was very very hard to do. Also,
he's trying to evade
uh enemy capture. Okay? So, this story
doesn't really make sense. And why did
Americans decide to create a landing
strip here rather than some place clo-
some place closer? And why would you
need 155
planes for this operation, right? Aren't
you better off with just one or two to
to like avoid enemy fire? So, this is a
very strange story.
But, it gets weirder, okay?
Um
it turns out
that the Americans basically spent a lot
of resources to to save the pilot. It
took 48 hours, and the CIA created a lot
of distractions.
And the uh Americans spent spent a lot
of resources to save the man while the
Iranians were trying to capture him,
okay? And this led to the destruction of
very expensive American planes.
Okay? These These are called C-130s, so
they're transport planes.
And they were destroyed in the rescue
operation. Now, the American story is
that these planes were caught in the
sand, they couldn't lift off. So, Delta
Force, the commandos who were trying to
save the pilot, they blew up the um
planes themselves, okay?
And as you can see, the Americans in
this operation, they lost a lot of
expensive planes. The estimates are the
Americans lost $300 million in
in planes.
And even though the Americans say that
there were no casualties in this rescue,
we can expect that there were casualties
in this rescue because a lot of planes
were destroyed, okay? And again, these
are very expensive planes.
And throughout this war, the Americans
have lost quite a few planes.
Um the C
um
uh 130
are extremely um expensive, okay?
All right.
Okay.
All right. So, this has led people to
question whether or not the narrative is
true or not.
Now, you can make the argument that this
narrative is true. You can make the
argument that the American military
prides itself on no man left behind, so
they would do whatever they can, move
heaven and earth, to save that person.
And that's something that Americans take
pride in. But again, there are issues
with this narrative. So, this is um a
man named Arnon Botran, and on Twitter,
he explains that the story doesn't
really make sense, okay? So, the first
thing is, how did a
fi- fighter jet, American fighter jet,
get knocked down in Iran when the
Americans have said that they have air
supremacy over the country. Another
issue is that
um
the
weapons director, sorry, the weapons
systems officer is a colonel. A colonel
is a very high-ranking individual in the
American military. So, why would he
participate in this operation? That's
very strange.
Um, and even though he was injured,
seriously wounded, according to Trump,
he still managed to hike up a 7,000 ft
mountain ridge line and hide in a
crevice in the Zagros Mountains for 48
hours despite his wounds.
Also, we don't know who he is.
He He's never been identified. He was
never interviewed by the press, which is
unusual because once because if you
rescue the man, you make him into a
national TV star, right? So, there are a
lot of issues with this story. All
right? So, um
Emma, could you do me a favor and just
read the summary? Okay.
So, to sum up, anti-aircraft equipment
that supposedly didn't exist shot down
an F-15 and apparently an A-10 Warthog
the same day. A seriously wounded man
climbed a 1.2.1
km
km mountain. The US seized an airfield
200 miles inside a country it's at war
with next to one of its most strategic
nuclear sites and deployed hundreds of
troops all apparently on unimpeded.
Lost two planes to sand and destroyed
their own helicopters. Videos show heavy
clashes, missiles raining down, but not
a single person got even wounded. And
the man at the center of it all, nobody
knows who he is, completely anonymous,
zero pictures, but Trump says he is safe
and sound. And so is the rescued A-10
Warthog pilot who also remains
anonymous. Okay, so again, this story
makes absolutely no sense.
Um, you we don't understand why they had
to build an airport. We don't understand
how these planes got destroyed. And the
fact that there are no casualties as
absolutely makes no sense whatsoever,
okay?
So, maybe something else is going on.
And people online are speculating that
this was actually a failed ground
invasion.
And the mission was to sneak into Iran's
nuclear power plant located in the area
and steal Iran's
uh enriched uranium, which it would need
to build a nuclear weapon, okay? And by
doing that, you deny the Iranians'
capacity to build a nuclear weapon and
you can declare victory, okay?
All right.
So, what's the evidence for this? On
March 7th, 2020
2026, so um at the beginning of this
war,
a journalist named Barak David
uh Barak Ravid wrote an article in
Axios, uh which is a Washington-based uh
media outlet, saying that the US is
considering sending special sending
special forces
to seize Iran's nuclear stockpile, okay?
Now, Barak Ravid is is famous in in
Washington, D.C. because he's very close
with the Israelis. He himself is
Israeli. So, he's able to get a lot of
information from the government, okay?
So, from March 7th onward, there was
news reporting that the Americans would
insert special forces to steal the
uranium. No one took this seriously
because it's so stupid.
Are you seriously going to send in like
a hundred guys into the middle of Iran?
And like hope they can sneak into a
military base and steal that uranium and
then run away? That's just No
one would do that, okay? So, everyone's
like, this is just This is just a psyop.
This is just disinformation, okay?
No one took this seriously. I didn't
take this seriously at all. But then,
4 days ago, I'm sorry, not 4 days, a
week ago, The Washington Post
leaks a Pentagon plan to do exactly
that. And it's a very detailed plan that
involves hundreds or thousands of
troops, okay? And the idea is to build a
landing strip near the power plant in
order to land forces in order to land
equipment.
So, this is a very detailed plan. The
problem So, when this first came out,
again, I didn't take it seriously
because this is so Are you
seriously going to build an airport by
yourself in the middle of Iran and hope
the Iranians don't notice?
And you're going to land a thousand
troops
in the middle of mountains where they're
going to rain missiles on you? It makes
no whatsoever, okay?
But, unfortunately,
if you just look at what happened this
weekend, this is the plan they used.
Where they sent 155 aircraft
to try to create a landing strip. They
sent in special forces.
It was exactly exactly the plan that
Washington Post reported on.
Okay? But, then the question is,
wait a minute here.
This is a top secret military plan. How
did the Washington Post get this?
Well, the answer is
because we assume that some generals
gave it to them, all right? Peter
Hoekstra, the Secretary of War for
Donald Trump,
fired the top generals
for
the military.
And we don't know why.
There was never a reason given.
Well, we can just suspect what happened
was this.
Donald Trump asked the generals to come
up with a plan to
steal the uranium. And the generals were
like, let's just humor him, okay? Let's
come up with this a stupid, insane plan
that there's no way this guy would agree
to, and then we'll forget about it. They
presented it to Donald Trump, and Donald
Trump was like, this is a brilliant
plan. This is a great movie. Let's do
this, guys. And the generals were like,
oh my god, he is insane. Oh my god, we
are so screwed, man. And they refused to
carry it out. So, Peter Hoekstra is
like, well, then you're fired, okay? And
then Peter Hoekstra orders the new
generals to execute this plan.
So, again, we don't know what happened.
We'll never know what happened, but the
evidence suggests that this this might
have been a failed ground invasion.
Another [snorts] piece of evidence to
suggest that this was a failed ground
invasion with the intention of stealing
the uranium is that the uranium were
able to recover ID
from
their in the crash site, okay?
And it turns out that this woman happens
to specialize in nuclear technology.
An engineer. Why would you need an
engineer who specializes in nuclear
technology to rescue a pilot?
Right?
That's kind of strange.
And the Americans have done stupid
things like this before, okay? So in
in 1980
um
the Americans implemented something
called Operation Eagle Claw.
And the idea was that
at this time the Iranians had taken
hostages, American hostages, in Tehran,
the American Embassy, okay? So Jimmy
Carter, the president, authorized a
rescue operation.
So but Iran was too big, so what they
did was the American military set up a
forward operating base in the desert,
halfway between uh Persian Gulf and
Tehran.
When they landed in their base, there
there's a sandstorm, and a lot of the
planes malfunctioned. And they
recognized that, "Oh my god, it's really
hard to go through with an operation in
Iran, so we should just go home, okay?"
So that was 1980, when Americans were
were pretty sane.
Unfortunately, Americans are no longer
sane, okay? This is January 3rd,
when [snorts] the Americans swept into
Venezuela and kidnapped their president,
Maduro, thus ending the conflict between
Venezuela and America.
This is great TV. The plan worked out
perfectly. It showed that Delta Force
was invincible. And unfortunately,
Donald Trump believes this, okay? He
believes that if we did this in
Venezuela, we We do this in Iran.
And this explains how and why Donald
Trump would agree to such an insane plan
as to try to build an American military
base in the middle of your enemy. Okay?
So, the main message here is that
whoever is leading America, whether it's
Donald Trump or the people, for whatever
reason, they believe
that optics is all that matters. Okay?
They think that reality is a movie, a
Hollywood movie. It's if they can script
it properly, then the movie will turn
out to be a wonderful, wonderful thing.
Okay? This is a war about optics rather
than strategy.
And unfortunately, this is just how
America's going to fight the war from
now on. Okay? So, let's just discuss
what you need to win a war. If you're
fighting a war, what are the three
things you need to look at? Okay? And
there are three things, and that's it.
First thing you want to look at is
economics.
Okay? Economics.
Second thing you want to look at
is organization.
The third thing you want to look at
is
logistics.
All right?
So, what what what what do I mean by
this? Well, the first thing is
resource management.
In other words, you're trying to win a
war as cheaply and as quickly as
possible.
Okay?
Unfortunately, right now, the Americans
are not fighting a war with economics.
If you're spending $300 million in
in military equipment in order to rescue
a pilot, you're not going to win this
war.
Okay? So, economics economics is really
it's really important. Secondly, is the
you have organization, which is the
implementation of strategy.
All right, so you have a strategy and
then [snorts] you
implement it. And here what's really
important is the simpler the strategy,
the easy easier it is to implement,
okay? You want the strategy to be very
simple because you have to organize it
and implement it. So, if you are trying
to build an airbase in the middle of
Iran so you can extract extract uranium
from the Iranians, that's not a good
organization, okay? This thing is going
to going to blow up in your face. The
third issue is logistics, which is just
supply, okay?
Supply.
Making sure that your forces have the
necessary equipment, the resources in
order to fight the war effectively.
And right now, the Americans are not
concerned with any of these issues. I
got economics, organization, and
logistics. But these are the three major
issues that you will need to figure out
if you want to win a war,
okay?
And unfortunately right now, the
Americans are too much focused on optics
and narrative.
So,
that's why I think the Americans will
ultimately lose this war because the
Iranians are actually fighting a real
war where they're trying to win the war
as cheap as possible where where they're
implementing a very simple strategy that
allows for proper organization and they
and they are trying to
maintain logistics, okay?
The Americans are just trying to
uh win the war
in the most Hollywood fashion as
possible. And this is going to lead to
disaster both in the short term and in
the long term.
So, the question then is
why are Americans like this?
And unfortunately, the answer is
because there's too much cooperation
between Hollywood and the Pentagon.
All right. So, this is a movie Sa-
Saving Private Saving Private Ryan in
the And this was made in the year 1998,
okay?
>> [snorts]
>> And this is one of the
um highest grossing the highest
grossing films in Hollywood history
where a private uh named Ryan, of
course,
he is lost behind enemy lines
in Europe.
And his brothers all killed. So, his
mother writes a very angry letter to
General Marshall and says, "All my sons
are dead except for one, and he's
missing."
And so, General Marshall is like, "We
can't have this. Okay, this is This
makes us look bad. We have to win the
home front, okay? Europe, this war
front, it's secondary to the home front.
We need to make sure that the American
people are fully behind this war." So,
he sends a team led by uh this man
played by Tom Hanks to go and save
Private Ryan.
And they do, but at the cost of his
life, okay?
And
this movie is based on a letter that
Abraham Lincoln wrote to a mother
in the American Civil War, okay? 1864.
And this is considered one of Abraham
Lincoln's
most um brilliant
pieces of writing. Okay, so, um Amber,
could you help help me read this,
please?
Dear Madam, I have been shown in the
files of the War Department a statement
of the
adjutant general of Massachusetts that
you are the mother of five sons who have
died gloriously on the field of battle.
I feel how weak and fruitless must be
any words of mine which should attempt
to beguile you from the grief of a loss
so overwhelming. But I cannot refrain
from tendering to you the consolation
that may be found in the thanks of the
Republic they died to save. I pray that
our heavenly Father may assuage the
anguish of your
bear
the bereavement
>> bereavement and leave you only the
cherished memory of the loved and lost
and the solemn pride that must be yours
to have laid so costly a sacrifice upon
the altar of freedom. Yours very
sincerely and respectfully, A. Lincoln.
>> Great, great, okay.
Um the sacrifice upon the altar of
freedom, okay? So our democracy, our
republic is our god and our sacrifice is
worth it as long as we can maintain
our freedom and our liberty, okay? And
this is the finding
theology of the American military.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right.
Um this has led to
the military becoming more of a
propaganda machine, okay? So this is the
movie Black Hawk Down. If you saw the
movie, then it's about these special
forces, Delta Force, that go in and save
a pilot
uh when they are when his hot helicopter
was brought down in uh Somalia, okay?
And this was a big based on a book by
Mark Bowden
writing about the incident which
happened in the late '90s,
okay?
All right. The problem is that this
movie is
complete BS.
In the book, what happened was that the
helicopter's brought down and the pilot
was taken hostage
by the Somalis. But he was treated very
well and eventually he was allowed to go
home after the government paid a ransom.
Okay? That's what happened in real life.
But, in the movie, what happened was
that Delta Force went in and saved the
pilot from those trying to kidnap him.
And this goes back to the to the
mythology of no man left behind. Now,
there's a very important scene in Black
Hawk Down where a general confronts
Delta Force.
And Delta Force was created for
operations like this. And what And what
the general says to Delta Force is,
"You guys are a bunch of cowboys."
And what he's saying is that, "You guys,
you Delta Force, you special forces, you
guys
never You guys think you're superior to
everyone. You think that we all revolve
around you. You think that we we we
should all serve you. You guys are
ego-driven. All you care about is glory
for yourself. And eventually, your ego,
your arrogance
are going to be are going to be your
downfall, as well as the downfall of the
American military. Okay?"
Um this is the movie This is Jessica
Lynch.
And in 2003,
she was serving in the war in Iran Iraq,
actually. Iraq, sorry.
And her her um her team got lost. And
they were ambushed by the Iraqis.
And then [snorts] she was um kidnapped.
But then, because she was injured, the
military The Iraqi military sent her to
a a hospital civilian hospital.
And the people in the hospital treated
her very very well. And they actually
tried to send her home in an ambulance.
But when the ambulance tried to reach
the Americans, the Americans bombed the
ambulance, so the ambulance had to turn
back.
Uh but but the Iraqis informed the
Americans where she was and told the
Iraqis you And then so told the
Americans, "You you can come and pick
her up anytime, okay? She's she's safe.
We're We're care of her. But if you want
but if you want to take her home, it's
okay. The Americans responds organized
special forces to go and rescue her,
even though she was not in danger. And
the media report that she was raped, she
was beaten, and she was
held hostage.
Okay? So, that's what the Pentagon does.
The Pentagon is a propaganda machine. It
doesn't care about the truth, it just
cares about trying to create
a Hollywood movie out of a movie. Okay?
So,
Pentagon is concerned first and foremost
about creating a Hollywood movie out of
a war.
That's its own that that's his its
mentality.
>> [snorts]
>> We know this because Jessica Lynch
after she was set free, went on TV and
said that the military is lying about
the incident. I was never beaten, I was
never in danger. The people in the
hospital treated me very nice. In fact,
the nurses sang me to sleep because they
were so concerned about my welfare.
All right?
All right.
So, this is a huge problem for the
American military for the Pentagon as
they fight this war. You can pull this
crap when you're fighting Somalis and
Iraqis, but against Iranians, you need
total war. You need to focus on
economics, organization, and logistics.
Stop doing this crap of optics, okay?
And narrative. Unfortunately, it's it it
has uh it is now the very mentality of
the Pentagon to turn war into a
Hollywood movie. All right? So, this is
a paper written by Tanner Mirrlees at
Brown University.
And what this author talks about is how
the Pentagon and Hollywood are aligned
together. All right? So, so so can you
read the three major take take aways um
um Amber? Sure.
In exchange for the use of military
equipment and personnel, movies and TV
program producers must comply with
Pentagon entertainment policy including
script changes to align with military
goals including recruitment and public
relations.
Since the inception of the Hollywood
entertainment industry more than a
century ago, over 2,500 war themed
movies and TV programs have been made
with Pentagon assistance.
Pentagon assisted movies movies and TV
shows frame US wars as necessary and
glorious downplaying that ignoring
downplaying or ignoring the human social
and environmental devastation war causes
particularly for civilians. US soldiers
are typically cast as noble protagonists
while those non-US peoples peoples
deemed enemies of America are constantly
stereotyped. Okay, so what this paper is
saying is that the Pentagon uses
Hollywood in order to indoctrinate and
brainwash American people to believe
that war is good.
Okay?
So that's true, but what's also true is
that by working with Hollywood
it brainwashes the Pentagon to believe
that war can be like Hollywood. It can
be perfected. As long as you create a
good script, it will work out in the
end.
Okay? And this will lead to disaster in
Iraq. So think about again Donald Trump
where
it's a failed ground invasion.
And so if it's a failed ground invasion,
what you do is you go back, you sit down
with Pentagon planners, and you figure
out what went wrong,
and how to never make the mistake again.
But Donald Trump does not want to admit
it was a failed ground invasion, so they
made a stupid Hollywood movie a stupid
Hollywood script that this was a rescue
of a American pilot
that they will turn into a Hollywood
movie at some point. And so, from their
perspective, this is a huge success.
Okay?
And this is going to lead to problems
because if it's a huge success, then do
it again.
Right? And if
people think it's failure, prove that
they're wrong by having success in
ground invasion.
Right? So, unfortunately, the fact of
the matter is that America right now,
American military, it's too dominated by
special forces, by Delta Force, by Navy
SEALs, who are interested only in their
own personal glory. Okay, I'm not saying
I'm not saying all of them, but I'm
saying there's quite a lot of them who
understand that
after this war is over, they can make
they can sign sign a book deal. They can
write a book, make millions of dollars,
which will be turned into a movie, and
they'll and then they'll be a superstar.
Okay? So, that's what that's how they
think.
And what they should be thinking about
are organization, logistics, and
economics because these are the three
things that win the wars.
All right? Okay, any questions, guys?
>> [clears throat]
>> I personally also think that America is
likely to um make a movie about saving
the pirates in Iran, but I think it will
be similar as uh Saving Private Ryan,
but could you please tell me whether the
plot of Saving uh Private Ryan is true
or is just made made it up?
Yeah, it it's it's it's just a made-up
movie.
Yeah.
Most of these things are are made up.
Okay? They didn't really turn out the
way that that they they do. But like the
problem with Hollywood is that it's so
seductive. It's so attractive that
people think that the movie is more true
than real life.
And that's how not only the Pentagon
works, but also like all of American
society works now, Americans live in
their own fantasy world created by
Hollywood. And the realities of war are
too far away from for them to care
about, okay?
I mean, Americans think that oh, at
worst case scenario, my my the food
prices will go up. They can't really
imagine how this war will ever forever
change the world as well as America.
Okay?
Um
Yeah.
How many more of these spectacle do you
think America can afford recreating? Or
let's say how many more times would
America like learn to understand that
this this like
like optical
Hollywood act will not no longer work
for their plan. Will they ever Will they
ever learn? Okay, that's a great um
question. The answer is they will never
ever learn, okay? Because they live in a
different reality. Like Donald Trump
surrounds himself with people who just
tell him what he wants to hear. And the
reason why he's able to go in front of
the press and say, "What a great success
in that that we had in saving the pilot,
okay?" The reason why The reason why
he's able to do that is because he
himself believes this.
Okay? He lives in alternate reality. A
fantasy land. And that's why he's able
to so to so convincingly
tell the press and American people that
this was a great success, even though if
you look at the evidence, this was a
tremendous failure. And unfortunately,
this will not change. As this war
continues, you have more instances like
this.
We We just say it it's a failure that
the American mi- military and and Donald
Trump
um spin as a tremendous success.
And so the American people will continue
to believe that this war is going well.
Okay? And And we know this because this
is exactly what happened in Ukraine. For
the past few years, Russia has been
dominating the battlefield
and has been
um killing many, many Ukrainians. It's
been a a disaster for Ukraine, but you
don't know this if you're American. If
if you're an average American, because
the news tell you that this war is going
great. One more day, guys, and Putin
will fall. One more day, the Russian
economy will collapse, the Russian
people will revolt, and Putin will be
out of office. One more day and the and
the Ukraine Ukrainians will reach
Moscow, okay? Same situation here where
one more day and Iran will surrender.
One more day, the Iranian economy
economy will collapse, the people will
revolt, and then we'll have peace in the
Middle East.
Okay? So, unfortunately,
this is modern war where it's really
about optics. But again, you don't look
at this war, don't focus on optics,
because ultimately, you're the one
fooling yourself.
Okay?
Yeah.
But despite that, America has thrown in
this kind of Hollywood and war scene,
but I think they still hold strong in
position and still hold the strongest uh
military weapon in the world, and they
still have, you know, the sovereignty to
state and control many of those
countries. How can you explain that?
Okay, you're actually right in that
America is still the empire, and America
will not fall because of this war.
Worst-case scenario, they lose, they
they go home, okay? So, one thing that I
I I
I want us to think think about is that
the strategic objectives of Americans
and the Iranians are not actually in
conflict with each other, okay? So, if
you look at the Iranians,
they want to
um get America out of Middle East.
All right?
They want to destroy the global economy,
and they want to deter Israel.
You know what I'm saying? These These
are the three strategic objectives of
Iran. To remove America out of the
Middle East forever, to deter Israel.
You can't destroy Israel because Israel
has a nuclear weapon, but you show
Israel you're strong and you you can
hurt them if you if Israel goes too far.
And you want to destroy the global
economy because you want to reset the
global economy in a way that benefits
you. Okay? So, these are three strategic
objectives of Iran in this war. Now,
let's look at America. America is Okay.
Um destroy
Iran
as a nation-state.
Okay? Which basically means you destroy
their desalination plants, their power
plants, their universities, their
reservoirs.
And you try to create ethnic conflict,
okay? Uh Balkanize
uh Iran, okay? So, you basically
encourage ethnic uprisings throughout
the
uh country, okay? Now, the last thing
you want to do is isolate Iran.
So, you want to destroy Iran's capacity
to trade with Russia and China, okay?
So, if you look at what's happening, one
really strange thing about this war is
that these strategic objectives are not
in conflict with each other. Even if
Iran is able to achieve its strategic
objectives, it doesn't prevent America
from achieving its strategic
objectives. So, in other words, at the
end of this war, what what we can expect
is both countries achieve their
strategic objectives, okay? Which is to
say that America is now out of the
Middle East. Um
Israel is humbled and the global economy
is destroyed.
But at the same time,
Iran is destroyed as a nation-state,
it's Balkanized, uh it's basically
bombed back to the Stone Age.
All right?
All right? Does that make sense?
Okay. So,
and unfortunately, because the two
strategic objectives are different, both
nations think they're winning the war.
All right?
Maybe objectively we think that America
is losing the war, but from the American
perspective, the way that they frame
their strategic objectives means that
from their perspective, they are winning
the war. And that's why they And that's
why they think that any day now Iran
will surrender.
But from the Iranian perspective, they
think they're winning the war and they
think that any day now America will
surrender. That's why it's impossible to
get the the two to negotiate a peace
settlement.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay.
All right. Okay. All right. So, on
Thursday, we're going to do something
really interesting, okay? We are having
a midterm examination.
But,
rather than me test you, you're going to
test me.
Okay? So, what I want you to do is think
about what we've learned this semester
and try to figure out where I could be
wrong
or where the problems in my logic are.
I want you to test me, okay? And this is
also true for YouTube, where um
if you think that there's something
wrong with my logic, if you dispute what
I say, then uh raise a question and then
my wife will read the YouTube comments
and then pick out questions for me to
answer on Thursday, okay? So, on
Thursday will be a midterm examination,
but rather than me test you, you will
test me.
Okay? And be as hard and as harsh and as
difficult as you want to be. I enjoy
being questioned and examined.
Okay? So, Thursday will be a lot of fun.
I'll see you guys then. Yeah.
>> Mhm.